why do you think this organization the
world tennis association is more willing
to get into a standoff with beijing than
the nba or the ioc which um of course
oversees the olympics and beijing's
gonna be hosting the olympics early next
year well i think a couple things all
pro sports leagues are trying to are
struggling with
how far do i go out and take a stand on
political and social issues and clearly
steve simon of the wta you know it's a
sexual assault matter it's an all-female
a professional sports league to me
that's a central issue and i admire them
for for taking the stand and i think
every situation and every league is is
slightly different but look it's a real
stand i mean their championships were
going to be played in china they had a
number of other events they've pulled
them back i mean that's the strongest
statement i've seen to date right and
they haven't even given any ground
either they've stuck to their guns in
terms of saying no
even after china released statements
from feng shui that she was okay they
said you know we don't believe that she
was saying that on her own free will
right so they're sticking up for their
values and things that they believe and
look this is human rights issue and it's
one that said close to home and you know
you have to admire him for taking a
stand but the bigger question is do
professional sports leagues still need
china it used to be that the benefits of
doing business in china outweighed the
downside
and it was worth it is china still worth
it well that's one of the things you
know there's a risk when you do business
in a communist country that doesn't
allow free speech i think you saw that
challenge with the nba it's more
difficult now in a social media world
and it's a balancing act and for some
leagues and federations china is going
to be more important than others
obviously there's a huge consumer base
but the risk of doing business in a
communist country that doesn't respect
human rights and free speech you know
there are real business risks and i
played out for the nba and it's playing
out today for the wta for the olympics
we'll see how that evolves here in the
next few months in your conversations
with people in the sports industry uh
people who are in the know do they see
the wta as an outlier or the beginning
of a broader shift you know i spent
today talking to a lot of leaders in
sports and asking them you know what are
they thinking about and this issue that
we're talking about today at the highest
levels is a question that everybody's
struggling with how far do i go on a
social or human rights issue what are my
business interests and how do i balance
them and i think it's something that
that people are struggling with right
now got it got it i mean by kind of
giving in cow towing to what the chinese
government wants the different sports
leagues and the nba felt this risks
angering fans at home and
abroad maybe in europe for instance um
we know china is a huge market 1.2
billion consumers it's kind of the holy
grail for any business in any industry
but isn't the rest of the world still
bigger i mean will sports leagues be
left in a position where they have to
pick one versus the other right i try to
have it both ways right so they're
trying to have it both ways and you may
not be able to do it and i think it
comes back down to your core values what
do you believe in human rights sexual
assault clearly a big issue for the wta
they're making a stand and i mean you
see this in other social issues
political issues you know it's a very
it's like any other business where do
you stand on these issues and i i think
it's a case-by-case situation and we'll
it's gonna it wasn't this way years ago
right sports was always something that
brought everyone together but now some
of these very divisive issues are making
sports having to take a stand which does
come with risk as well so there's a risk
of doing something but there's also a
risk of doing something and you know in
a very sensitive situation when you say
nothing you're actually saying something
and this is a line that all these
leagues and federations are going to
straddle and of course it's amplified by
social media as well so i think this is
a challenge that's going to evolve for
all leagues moving forward yeah not
taking action is the decision that
you're making right george thank you so
much george pine is founder and ceo of
bruin capital from bloomberg quick take
i'm scarlet foe